three businesses were hit a string of
early morning burglaries in Northeast
Port City in deine robbed and carjacked
at gunpoint this is not the city we once
knew crime is Skyrocket and the homeless
prices has reached a breaking pointed on
side PR how and why is this
happening
it it is extremely frustrating for us to
take the steps that we believe and
frankly that we know we need to take as
a municipal government to address open
drug use or to address addiction or to
address unsanctioned dangerous and
squalid camps in our community we're
responsible to the public for the right
of way we're responsible to the public
for Public Safety and yet we don't have
all of the tools we need at the
municipal level to be able to get done
what we need to have done and so the
courts often uh intercede as they did on
our time place and manner restrictions
around camping uh and of course the
legislature preempts us from being able
to enforce drug use laws here in the
city of Portland I've been very clear
about what my goals are I do not want
anyone using or dealing drugs on our
streets I do not want anyone camping on
our streets in unsanctioned homeless
camps and all of our policies are Al in
alignment with those goals but with the
understanding that we'll be Humane in
our approach we will try to offer people
other tailored Services whether it's
drug treatment whether it is Behavioral
Health Services whether it's job
training whatever people need to get off
and stay off the streets and stop using
drugs and go into treatment and get the
help they need to recover their lives
and improve our community but I need the
governor and I need our legislature and
I need our County government to work
with us to get it done and I realize
that for a lot of people that means
they're going to have to change their
views particularly around homeless Camp
sweeps uh their views around drug use uh
and other areas but if they really want
to see this community improve the way it
needs to improve they need to get into
line with what this city council is
doing we're unified as a city council
and and we have a great team here at
City Hall working hard but if if the
courts and the legislature uh and other
political players in the state who who
hold sway over what we do uh continue to
block us it makes our job all that much
harder we'll work around them we'll find
other Solutions but it would be great if
we could all get on the same
page anyone who walks around the streets
of Portland is likely to see some one
who um is in the grips of pentanol
addiction um this literally kills
hundreds of portlanders every year we
have to do a much better job of managing
this I think given how dangerous this
drug is um criminalizing it with the
goal of of using that as an incentive to
connect people to uh treatment is really
important but I'll tell you even beyond
that um there's the question of should
we re- criminalize the consumption of
fentol another question which needs to
be addressed in this legislative session
which means before 2024 is over the
governor and our state lawmakers really
need to give local governments like
Portland the authority to regulate the
consumption of drugs on our streets and
sidewalks the city of Portland can make
rules about where you can smoke a
cigarette but I cannot make any binding
rules about where you smoke Fen andol um
that is part of the reason why Portland
looks the way it does and that needs to
change and it's within the power of our
state lawmakers to get that done and I'm
calling on our partners down in Salem to
please do that in the short
[Music]
session we need to give tools to uh our
First Responders so they can take action
so if someone is smoking fentanyl in
public and it's causing harm to those
who are trying to access the the
sidewalk then the police need to be able
to respond to that and so I think it's
just common sense we want to make sure
that we edit 110 um before it just
completely goes away oregonians are not
happy with how it's been implemented and
it's our job as uh legislators and
public servants to listen to that and
admit that we have to roll it out with
some
improvement the no daytime camping was a
big deal but now it's it's locked up in
the courts a bit and we're going to end
up winning this challenge because the
fact is we need to provide services for
people who are on the streets um during
the day and we need to free up our
public RightWay so that people can
merely uh if you're an elder and you
live um downtown you should have the
right to walk around your blocks
peacefully if you're a parent and you
want to access a park you want to go
there without having to go around people
doing drug
[Music]
use